[Music]
here are all the best things to buy
inside Disney's new Star Wars Galaxies
edge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right doc connors denim
entities which is the workshop obviously
they have everything
[Music]
if you're a Star Wars fanatic you're
gonna be on Cloud City when you see how
much there is to buy
[Music]
this is where you build your own droid
so you like pick up a piece and then put
in a basket and then they'll help you
build it over there which is really
really really cool but it's hundred
bucks we can afford that so
what you pick I think an r2 unit because
some of the top oil T the toys like
these moving kawaki and monkey lizards
are seemingly endless a fan favorite is
this flying pork of course you can build
your own lightsaber
[Music]
that is fun obviously there are tons of
cost I am the smart aleck night I don't
think this is the spark with Dignity
resist me an accident who doesn't want
to buy a replica of Emperor Palpatine
skåne or whatever this thing is or this
lot
[Music]
this is horrifying the toys I think are
the best part galaxies that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're feeling a little spendy you
can buy jewelry inspired by the films
[Music]
[Music]